There's been a lot of talk
lately about the fiscal cliff,
which sounds very dramatic.
And what I want to
do in this video
is at least lay
out the numbers so
that we're all on the same page.
And then the next few videos,
think about the implications
or how the negotiations between
the president and Congress
might actually work out.
So the first thing to
frame this conversation
is just where the
budget is right now.
And so let me draw
a little graph.
So let me make this axis right
over here represent our budget.
I want to make it
as big as possible
so that we can get a little
bit of granular detail
on how much the budget
might move based
on how the
negotiations work out.
So let's say that this line
is roughly $4 trillion long.
So that's $4 trillion,
and halfway would
be about $2 trillion.
And then in between two and
four, you've got $3 trillion.
And then $1 trillion would be
right over here, $1 trillion.
And then I'm going
to do some bar
charts to show the
different scenarios.
And as I do this, keep in mind
the size of the US economy.
The US economy is
approximately $15.5 trillion.
So that is roughly our
GDP, depends on which year
you're measuring.
But that gives us at
least a frame of reference
for what chunk of
GDP we are talking
about when we talk about
the federal budget.
So let's start with the 2012.
Let's start with
the 2012 budget.
So in 2012, the US government
is spending $3.6 trillion.
So let me make my graph a
little bit more granular.
So this would be 3.5.
So 3.6 is going to
be right around here.
So let me draw that.
And I'll do it in this purple
color for the expenditures.
So this is how much the
federal government spent
or I guess is spending in 2012.
So just like that.
All right, there we go.
So that's expenditures.
Now you are probably
aware that we
don't have all of the revenue.
We didn't bring in the
$3.6 trillion in taxes.
So this right over
here is $3.6 trillion.
Our revenue that we get through
tax revenue and other things
is somewhat less.
It, in 2012, was on the
order of $2.5 trillion.
So I'll draw that
right over here.
So $2.5 trillion.
I'll do it in this green color.
So this is how much
revenue was brought in.
So let me write this down.
This is $2.5 trillion.
Now let's think
about how much might
get spent under the
different scenarios.
So first I'll lay out a rough
approximation of Obama's budget
proposal for 2013.
So Obama in 2013.
So on the spending side, he
sees, or he would like to see,
spending go up by $200 billion.
So let's see this.
So on the spending side, we're
going to add $200 billion.
And the next few
videos, we could
talk about the pros
and cons, the arguments
for and against
something like that.
So let me draw that.
So relative to the 3.6,
we're now that 3.8.
So you have a spending increase
of-- so plus $200 billion.
That gets us to 3.8 billion
in total expenditures.
If my best estimate of what
the Republicans in Congress
would want.
So let's write.
Let's say, a Republicans in
2013 is that they would actually
ideally want spending
cuts from these levels.
So let's draw that out.
And roughly on the order
of about $100 billion.
So roughly on the
order of $100 billion.
They might even
want more than that,
but let's just go
with that for now.
So that gets us to a
budget of $3.5 trillion.
That's about that
right over there.
$3.5 trillion.
So once again, relative
to 2012, you're
going down by $100 billion.
Let me make clear.
You're subtracting $100 billion.
Now in the fiscal
cliff scenario,
the spending will be similar
to the Republican ideal right
over here.
So let me write this over here.
Fiscal cliff.
We are also spending.
We are cutting on the
order of $100 billion
in government expenditures.
So let's draw that.
So at least on the
expenditure side.
And these are all very rough.
I'm sure the Republicans
who would agree and disagree
with this.
But I'm trying to get
my best sense of kind
of an aggregate view on things.
So the fiscal cliff.
We are also cutting
spending by $100 billion.
Now let's go to the
revenue side of things.
In all of these scenarios for
2013, and just to be clear,
the fiscal cliff
that's also for 2013.
And all of these scenarios,
we get the same revenue
that we got in 2012.
So let me draw that.
Plus we get about
another $100 billion
from the growth in the economy.
As the economy grows, and
even if your tax rates are
held completely
constant, you're going
to get more revenue for
the federal government.
You get about $100 billion
from the federal government.
And so that gets
us to $2.6 trillion
without changing anything.
So let me just shade all
of these in really fast.
So shade that one in.
Shade that one in.
And then, shade that one in.
Now, as you've probably
heard on the news,
Obama would like to
extend the Bush tax
cuts for the middle class.
And he considers a
middle class of those
who are making less than
$250,000 for a family.
But he would like to not extend
the Bush tax cuts on the rich.
And he would like to actually
include a few other tax
increases, also on the wealthy.
And so you would get
an increase of revenue
under Obama's plan
of $300 billion.
This is once again, very rough.
Probably $50, $60 billion that
I'm not fully accounting for,
but it'll give you
the rough picture.
So this is $300 billion.
And what Obama's doing here, or
what at least in the proposal,
as far as I can believe,
none of this is that simple.
What they're talking
about right over here
is extend tax cuts for middle
class, which my best reading,
seems like we would lose a
little under $200 billion
of revenue.
But then we keep the tax
cuts or we let the tax cuts
on the wealthy expire.
So that gets us 200 of this.
And then there are
other tax increases
and another removing
loopholes and whatever
else they increase
this to $300 billion.
So let's compare the deficit.
So this gets us to,
in the Obama scenario,
we end up with $2.9
trillion in revenue.
So let's compare
what the deficit did
from 2012 to
Obama's budget plan.
So in 2012, if you
take $3.6 trillion,
subtract out $2.5 trillion,
there is a gap $1.1 trillion.
This is the deficit.
This is how much the government
has to borrow in 2012.
Under Obama's budget,
what would it be for 2013?
Well we're spending
$3.8 trillion.
We are getting a $2.9 trillion.
So you have a gap
of $900 billion.
So there is some of
the deficit reduction,
although the deficit
is still quite large.
The deficit reduction
is $200 billion.
$100 billion of that came
from the economic growth.
And then, the rest is coming
from, or a good chunk of that,
is coming from increased taxes.
Depending on how you view
it, either increase taxes
on the wealthy or not
letting the tax cuts
expire on the wealthy.
Now let's think about
the Republican situation.
Well, you have $2.6
trillion in revenue.
And you have $3.5 trillion.
Let me write this down.
And once again, you have on the
order of a $900 billion gap.
So in terms of
deficit reduction,
these things look
pretty similar.
You have a very similar deficit.
Obama is increasing spending.
And he would argue
that he's investing
in things that might help
stimulate the economy,
or invest in America
for the future.
And then he's making it
up by letting the tax cuts
on the wealthy expire
for the most part.
The Republicans want
to cut spending.
But they're also letting
the tax cuts continue.
So you essentially have the
same level of deficit reduction.
Now I think we are ready to
talk about the fiscal cliff.
The fiscal cliff, we're
spending hundreds billion less.
And then we are also letting
all of the tax cuts for both
the wealthy, those
who are earning
at a family level
more than 250,000.
And for the middle class,
we're letting them all expire.
And so you have the revenue
increase by $400 billion.
So this goes up by $400 billion.
And so that takes us
roughly, once again,
this is all rough,
to about $3 trillion
in revenue and $3.5
trillion in expenses.
And so your deficit, under
the fiscal cliff scenario,
the deficit is going
to be $500 billion.
Now you might say,
hey, this is great.
Everyone talks
about the deficit.
The deficit is a scary thing.
We are borrowing from
the future and all that.
Why are people so afraid
of the fiscal cliff?
The reality is that if
you take $500 billion
out of the economy.
So $100 billion through spending
cuts and then $400 billion
from tax increases.
So the government
is deleveraging.
But that money's being
sucked out of the economy.
And you could argue that there's
just kind of a multiplier
effect as well, that might
endanger what's already
a very precarious
risk of recovery.
That the recovery is really
just starting to happen.
And if we were to suck all of
this money out of the economy,
that's what the
argument would be,
then that might throw us
into another recession.
Or that might make the
recovery that much weaker.
In the next few
videos, we'll discuss
that in a little bit more depth.
See what people are saying
the impact might be.
And what the arguments
might be in either case.